should I try this XXL chess
like what is this even are there rules
I click the question mark but how do you
how do the camels move
is it even a camel or is an alpaca
maybe a llama
well we'll just figure it out actually
there's a beginner mode right
ah this is a night Queen
and this is a night King
and this is a wow a camel can move like
this
what
I'm trying to see the the highlights are
so faint
so it's like a supercharged Knight
so it moves like this
wow
so what are the undefended Pawns
I think this Pawn looks undefended
see if I can attack it somehow
okay I'm developing developing my um
what do I even call this a queen a nice
like
a night Queen
a quite okay a quite I like I like the
quite
so I want to use my quite
this Pawn
s offended though
let's develop my other camel
wait a minute
this is my light swear camel this is my
darksword camel camels have to stay on
the same colored Square
wow
okay I accidentally defended my Pawn I
didn't even see that that was attacked
well I defended it
so I assume this like is a combination
of a king and a knight
so a kite
but this is a this is my real king
so the goal is to win the real king I
should develop my Bishops
I just realized this is a long diagonal
that's a really long feeling cattle
oh pawns promote at the eighth rank
is this the eighth rank
uh to stop the pawn from promoting
wait one two three four five
oh this is okay this is a oh there's a
small dot in the middle I don't people
see that
but that signifies the center so the
pawn is really close to removing
oh and it's supported by the the uh the
kite
okay let's push my H Pawn then
I want to make a new piece as well
so what's the most powerful piece in
this game it's got to be the kite right
the camel doesn't actually seem so
powerful
it just seems annoying
oh this bishop wants to take my camel
oh
I can blockade the pawn with my camel
it's a camel blockade
this Pawn can't promote anymore
I missed out the previous move
yeah so the camel Moves In Like A
a really long l
it's like a normal L but a longer l
oh that's annoying how do I reinforce my
camel
I'm gonna play this move
so my
I guess I'll call this the hawk it
defends the camel
I just realized that King is kind of
exposed
not easy to attack though
oh dear
becoming a real focal point
oh I could have Superfluous camels
look at this
oh like well camels don't move like that
though
I can't have Superfluous camels
uh
uh so there's two attackers only one
Defender I just realized this is Blitz
chest too
I'm not gonna have so much time
can I somehow Fork these pieces
oh look at this move
attacking attacking
defending I just played kite to h8
attacking The Rook on n14
I just realized there was notation
I'm also attacking this Pawn which is
somehow undefended
oh my quite quite kite
wait what's a kite oh the the kite is a
king Knight
so let's take this
and pre-move this
oh no my camel
wait what oh the camel defends
I got skewered
nice move
man my phone's good at this game
I mean I could take
that's okay
at least I attacked the bishop
I could have also delivered check
and then taken taken
I forgot there was some there's some um
checking ideas
I should have delivered this check
I was blind to that
I could have saved my my Hawk
and it's getting crazy though
my quite wants to go on a
eating spree
are those pawns attacked
oh the camel's defended though by the
kites
I just realized normal nights are just
terrible in this game because the board
is so open
oh no it's a queen
why does the Queen have one on it
I just realized this Pawn's defended by
the camel
if I take I should take the bishop
because Bishops are way more valuable
than Knights
I also just realized there's a battery
the
the quite and the Queen have the battery
against my Pawn on G2
and so it feels so weird to call this a
G2 Pawn
this is my end Pawn
okay so now do I take this
I think I do
and then I'll take this
defending my Bishop from a very long
distance and also trapping The Rook
oh I forgot about the camel
I saw that earlier too I just forgot
about it
oh no my quite
that was my most powerful piece too
my time is getting low oh this is not
going to be pleasant
can I Castle in this game
don't hurt me
I'm trying to sneakily defend this Pawn
I have to play defense now
I still want to take the Rook too
is your increments
what does this mean what was what
happens if the time like if the white
disappears
what's gonna happen
uh
uh let's take
foreign
stuck now I mean I can move here though
can you plan
push my a pawn
I just realized this Pawn is kind of
weak although it's defended by my kite
and my king
is there no increments
there's no increment I'm gonna have to
maybe like start removing everything
[Music]
oh no there is increment
oh dear we're both promoting
okay I'll take that
Dove Bishops don't move like that ah
foreign
diagonal doesn't quite work like that
oh good move okay let's play this
hitting the knights
hitting the Knight again my Knight's
defended by the quite though
I'm in trouble
okay hitting this
opponent's also getting low on time
oh no my Pawn
ah
and start attacking the king let's check
it's so close to meeting oh I just lost
a thing
take that
let's go coming back
let's go
don't mess with my camel
wait how am I how's my camel move
oh did I take that I don't think I
should take that I was defended by the
camel
what just happened
okay Rooks are very powerful in this
game
also pawns are surprisingly useful in
the end game
or unsurprisingly useful
that's a good move
ah
free piece
wow new Queens are born
[Music]
I want to play this move
I'm threatening me to no I'm not
threatening Maiden one
it was defended by the camel
oh the sneaky camel
you just want to get rid of the camel
okay now I'm turning made in one
Ah that's not quite meat
nice
very nice
attack
where's my mate
nothing oh I hung Queen I forgot it
could move like that
okay check
oh no my queen
doesn't see it though
it's so hard to remember How the Camel
moves
okay I'm winning all the Pawns
kind of latternays
what other pieces do I have
oh let's check haha sneaky camel
Oh no you're a queen
this has been hanging for a while
oh
oh
what's happening
Chuck
the camels are so confusing I have a lot
of Pawns though
Jack
no
oh there's so many blunters
the Pawn's got a queen
I need to think
there
I need to make a punching
I'm in bad shape though
am I gonna lose us
foreign
[Music]
this is not good
don't hurt me
foreign
stop hurting me
stop it
oh no I'm pinned
don't Wi-Fi ah
what a crazy game that was 121 moves or
121 moves and then I flat
good game